では よろしくお願いします
今日はまあストレス 一応私は発音は少々このストレスとは言わないので
これすぐ忘れます 頑張ってそのような発音をしようかなと思っても
ですから そこら辺はまず考えていてください
ストレスの解消方法ということでお話しさせていただきたいと思います
こういうのは現代的な言葉ですから
もう確実に仏教でなんぞやということはないんですけどね
仏教っていうのはすごい人格的に完成している
知恵が完成している人間を作るための教えですから
まあそこら辺でまあどうやったらラーメンがよく売れるかぐらいのね
希望にもう応える なんかもったいないんですよ
だからお店に大厄れというような感じですからね
で 家の床付けにはつける石がちょっと軽いんだと
もっと重いダイヤでもないのかと聞いたってもね
まあそこら辺で何かで間に合いますけど
まあそういうことですから
まあ一応それでもまあ
だからちょっと話続けちゃうと
結構まあ自分が予測しているところじゃないんではないかと思うかもしれません
結構レベルが飛んでいくと思います
まあそれはしょうがないんです
ですから まあ皆様の顔を見ると
ストレスなんかは全然あるようにもしないし
見えないし だからちょっと遅くしてみたんで
ストレスもかかってるのはあんまりあまり気にしてないで
遅くなった方がいいかな
もったいないと思っているかもしれません
で では話を続けていきます
まず あの仏教用語でストレスというと
まあどういう言葉使えるのかと
で まあ仏教っていうのは当然皆様ご存知のように人間の心の説明をしているんですよ
魂の説明でも天国の説明でもないんです
自分たちの我々の心の働きを説明しているんですよ
だったらもうきめ細かく何だかんだも説明しているはずなんです
それで説明だけじゃないんですよ
完全に心を完全な状態にする方法
その道も指導しているんです
だから心の分析ですから
人間が不幸になる原因
幸福になる原因 なんでそうなるのかどうか
どうすれば不幸になる原因を減らせますかと
まあ幸福ってどんなものかと
心の それは心の感覚ですからね
それは本当に本当の幸福なのかどうかね
そういうところらへんで説明がありまして
では完全たる境地って何なのかと
その境地に至るためにどうすればよろしいかというふうな状況で説明はしてあります
それで そこまで言っているのに
しかし ストレスに適する言葉はありません
あれほどものすごい膨大な量ですよ
心の分析っていうのは
信じられないほどきめ細かく説明しています
なのにストレスに適する
適合する言葉がないんです
まあないと言えば もっと仏教用語を知っている方々に怒られるかもしれませんだけど
まああるのはあるんだけど
専門用語としてないんです
で 今日はもうそこら辺もちょっと紹介しようかなと思ったんですけど
時間が間に合わないんです
ですから控えますが あることはありますけど
あれは一般用語であって
専門用語ないんですよ
ということは このストレスということ
現代人に突然現れた現象でしょうかね
昔の人々になかったもので
今現在突然現れたものでしょうか
サースウイルスみたいに
あるいは鳥インフルエンザみたいに BS
みたいに突然 現れてもうどうしようもない
今もあの 免疫ね 機能壊すエイズウイルスとかね
いまだにもうどうしようもないんでしょう
それはすべて現代病なんですね
だからストレスというのはもうそんなような感じで
現代人にだけあるものなのかということも考えた方がいいんです
あるいはまあ 仏教で言葉がないということは
仏教というのはそんな我々のストレスなんかには当てにならないのかと
仏法を聞いたっても ストレスなんかには役に立たないのかということを考えた方がいいのです
それはなんで用語ないのかということはなんです
だから 用語ないならば
仏教の見方違うでしょうと思います
それでストレスの意味理解した方がいいと思います
それでストレスの意味なんですけど
では現代心理学でも社会で明確な定義ありますかね
ストレスというのはこういうものであると 2つの定義が必要ですよ
体の感覚 体に対して定義と心理学的な定義と
いわゆる医学的な定義と心理学的な定義というのは 2つ必要です
ないんです と思います
皆様 専門家がいらっしゃるならば
どうぞ教えてください
心理学の専門家がいらっしゃるならば
ストレスというのはこういうものであると定義ございますか？私はあまり勉強してないんです
医学の世界でもストレスに定義があるのかと
じゃあ私の主観で言えば定義はない
したがって解決方法も様々ですよ
定義ないんだから まあこうすればいいんじゃないか
ああすればいいんじゃないかというふうに
暗闇でなんとか探るしかなくなってますね
複数の解決方法があるということは
どちらでも完全ではないということです
そこでストレス解消方法としていろんなことありますよ
民間治療方法もありますね
それから専門家の治療法もあります
でも ほとんどの場合は民間治療法で
我々はなんとかしてストレス解消します
で これがひどい状態になると
どこかの心理系の専門家やらお医者さんやら誰かに会って
なんとか治療してもらう
だからストレスの原因で胃腸炎になったり
他の体のいろんな病気になってくると
普通の医者を訪ねるでしょう
そこで医者にしても原因はわからないということを言うんですね
だから一応 症状を抑えるために
こういうこういう風にしましょうということになるんです
心理学者のカウンセラーのところに行ったら
まあそれなりのなんとかカウンセリングするでしょうと思いますけど
でも方法は様々ですよ
ということは これという適応した方法はないんです
なぜないのかというと
ストレスは何なのかがわかってないだからなんです
普段はそれは危険ですけどね
病気は何なのかとわからないんだけど
手当たり次第薬を飲まされるということは
もう法律違反でしょうし
大変なことになります
しかし ストレスの場合は
まあこれは堂々とやってます
そういうことだから そのポイントについて結論として言えるのは
ストレスって何なのかとわかってないんだから
あんた方はストレス解消方法もわからないでしょうと
で 続けてストレスの意味について語ります
人が楽しいことをしていてもストレスが溜まるんですよ
なんかよく聞かれますよ
楽しいことをすればストレス解消するんではないかと
違うんですよ 楽しくてふざけて遊ぶと結構ストレス溜まっちゃうんです
あー今日は一日中遊びすぎて
もうどうしようもないって
いろいろやることあるんじゃないかなと
こんなことではダメな人間になるんではないかとかね
結構ストレス溜まってるんですよ
では 睡眠を取ったらどうでしょうかと
すごく自己嫌悪になるんですよ
自分がちゃんと今日はほとんど寝ていて
まあどうしようもないんだと
こんなことをやっていられないんではない
これ ストレスなんですよ
だから 嫌なことをしていても
ストレス溜まる それでみんなよく言うのは
この集中して何かやっているとストレス溜まらないんだと
やってみてください かなりストレス溜まっちゃうんですよ
ものすごいストレス溜まっちゃうんです
では レジャーに取り込んだら
まあこれいろいろみんな言ってる方法なんですよ
レジャーがあれば このレジャーっていうのは
まあ英語のレジャーではありません
これは日本語で皆様が考えているレジャー
レジャーですね で これ
この単語だけは一応意味を調べたんです
英語のレジャーでしょうかと見たら
違うんだそうです で まあ日本語でレジャーというのは持て余った時間なんですね
それが贅沢に楽しく過ごすということ
だから まあ英語でレジャーっていうのは
この休み時間という意味なんです
仕事以外の時間でまあ楽しく過ごすということ
だから まあまあ休憩時間ですね
だから休憩時間を有意義に使う場合はレジャーと呼ぶんです
余ってる時間ではないんです
それに取り込んでも結局はストレス溜まるんです
このレジャー レジャーの時間
時も随分時間気になります
例えば 2 日間時間があったりすると
もう全部ちゃんと計画を立てて
もう結構終わりになってくると
もうさっさともう仕事に帰ろうという
ということは では何もしないでいたらどうする？それは違うでしょうね
何もしないでいると もうものすごいストレスかかるんですよ
何もやることないんだといえば
もう生きていられなくなっちゃうでしょう
そういうことで 専門家の話を聞くと
よく聞こえるのは まあストレスは必ずあるという意見なんですね
人間であるならば もうそれはもう必ずもついてるものであると
いわゆるストレスない人間はいないというふうな考え方があるんです
だからわからないのは
嫌なことをやったらストレスが溜まって
楽しいことをやると溜まらないんだったら定義できますよ
人が嫌なことをやると溜まる感覚がストレスであると
あるいは仕事を何もやることがない
何もやることがないと溜まるんだったら
もう解決方法もありますよ
人間が常に何かやっていればいいんだよと
そうするとストレス溜まらないんだよと
そう簡単にはいかないんですね
これが ストレスというものは
嫌な存在ですよ 何にも過ぎてくる
そこで世の中でよくやることは
仕事をもうというか やること淡々淡々と変えるんですよ
仕事をする途中でやめて
タバコを吸う また仕事をする
またそれ途中でやめて
お茶を飲む また仕事をする
またそれやめて ちょっと新聞でも何かちょっと読んでみる
また仕事をする またそれやめて
またタバコを 1本吸うとかね
そうやっても もうかなり早く
もう何て言いますか もう仕事を変えて変えて変えて変えていくんですよ
これで解決するかというと解決しないんです
なぜならば そういう小さなことをやってもストレス溜まるんですよ
だから結局 1日終わるとストレス溜まってるんです
それだけじゃないんです
そうやって仕事を変えて変えてやると
仕事をする タバコを吸う
仕事をする お茶を飲む
仕事をする 冊子を読む
仕事をする もうちょっと他の何かをやる
仕事をする またタバコを 1本吸うとか
そんなことだから 仕事は途切れ途切れ
途切れ途切れ 途切れ途切れなんですね
そうすると なんとなくもう仕事に対する能力も出てこなくなっちゃうし
まあやる気がどんどん温かくなってきたところは消えてしまうんですよ
一番悪いのはこのものを書く時なんですよ
体のあるいはただ整理
体の仕事だったらそんな難しくないんです
止まったところから始めればいいんです
あるいは経理関係のことだったら
もうデータを打っているところだったら
止まったところから打ちでいいんですけど
考えてする仕事の場合は最悪なんです
しかし かなり仕事を回転させてるのはそういう人々なんですよ
ものを書く人っていうのは
だいたい 1時間でタバコをもう 20 分ぐらい
30 分ぐらい吸ってしまっちゃうんです
だから別な仕事をしたら途端
あの思考の流れが切れちゃうんです
そこで今まで何を書いてきたんでしょうか
何を考えてきたんでしょうかと
またやり直さなくちゃいけないんですよ
これ ものすごい最悪だと思いますね
そのストレスは 体の仕事の場合は
ほんのちょっとお茶飲んで一休みしちゃうと体が怠けちゃうんですよ
もうちょっと腰をかけていたくなっちゃうんです
それで仕事にまだ入るのはちょっと難しくなっちゃうんです
だからそういういろいろ能率が減るんです
とにかくどちらにしても
そういうわけで ストレスの正体って何なのかと考えてみましょう
これ一番目に書いてることはわかりますね
何をしても溜まるものだからね
理解しがたいんですね
それでストレスという一言葉で言うんですけど
まるっきり同じものでしょうかね
楽しい時 溜まるストレスと
嫌なことをする時 溜まるストレスというのは全く同じですかと
それ考えた誰もそういうことを考えないんですよ
例えば 何もやることない時
溜まるストレス 仕事がありすぎて溜まるストレス
同じですかね なんか楽しくいろんな楽しいことを踊ったり
音楽を聞いたり もうなんとかやったりしている時
溜まるストレス まあそれちょっと考えておけばいいんで
例えば映画を見たりすると楽しいでしょうと
音楽を聴きに行きましたと
どこかのオーケストラなんとかとかね
聞きに行きましたと これこそ人間にとって楽しいことやと
結局みんなすごく疲れるでしょ
割と 映画を見る時でもポップコーン持っていくんですね
大体は 決まりはね 日本ではそれほど激しくはないんですけど
まあいろいろ食べ物あるんだから
ポップコーンには限ってないんです
ポテトチップス食べてる人もいるし
コーヒー飲んで映画見る人もいるし
あるいは合間で何か本を読んだりする人もいるし
携帯でメールやる人もいる
なんとかなんとかしているんです
そんなに楽しいんだったらやる必要ないんですけど
それで終わっちゃうと
誰でもさっさと  ではどこかで行ってご飯でも食べましょうと
それでストレス解消しようとしてるんですよ
結局は映画見たってもストレス溜まってるんです
そういうことを考えておいた方がいいんです
何をしても溜まる それで一番考えてほしいのは
同じものですかと このストレスというものは
もし同じものでないならば
体に良いストレスと体に悪いストレスなんかあるのかと
それも考えた方がいいんです
で そういう考えって世の中にありますよ
専門家の間で 体に心に良いストレスもありますよと
悪いストレスもありますよと
まああの  ちょっと飛ばして言いますけど
一応2種類があるんです
ストレスは体に悪影響を与えるものと
体だけではなくて 人間に悪影響を与えるものをストレスと良い影響を与えるストレス
だから良い良い影響を与えるもののストレスと言っちゃう
言っちゃうと なんかね
事に当たらないんですね
この英語のストレスという言葉も
何の意味かというと あんまりわからない
まあ一応疲労ということだからね
ストレスは日本訳すれば疲労なんです
あれって何の意味でしょうかね
テンションという言葉はありますよ
それも心理学で使いますね
これ テンションというのは日本語では
日本語になると同じ言葉でテンションって言うんですけど
これ悪いと思ってないんです
それは日本訳すると緊張感なんですね
テンションは まあなんかまあストレスさえもはっきりわかってないんだから
一応仏教の立場から言うと
やっぱり 2つあります
仏教は明確に定義するんですよ
人間人格向上する衝動ですね
それが良いもので いても立ってもいられない状態になる
こんな調子ではダメやと
もう専心しなくちゃいけないんだという状態が良いストレスなんです
ああ 嫌だ もう何もやりたくないという風になる衝動が悪いストレスなんです
で その場合は 仏教では専門用語を別々にあります
で 残念なことにそれが訳できないんですね
だから良いストレスあるということは
仏教以外誰もわかってないみたい
緊張感なんですけど ストレスほとんど似てるんですよ
もういてもたってもいられない状態
だからといって破壊的ではなくて
もう進んでしまおうという
例えばこれ例えあります
例えでわかるんですよ
人が家に住んでいる すやすやと寝ている
寝ている時は突然音が聞いて
なんかやけに熱くなっちゃって目が覚める
覚めるともう壁やらそこら辺はもう火がついちゃって
もうパチパチと燃えている
もう手に負えない あっちこっちからもう下から火が上がっている
家にある消火器ではもう全くもうダメですね
その時は頭のいい人だったら
落ち着いている人だったらどうしますか
瞬時に逃げるんです 私たちだったらキャーキャーキャーキャーと泣いて
そのままもう死んじゃいますけれどね
で 消防車の電話番号まで忘れちゃいます
それわかってますから
もう 110番押しても
190でしたっけ？ 119です
何を押しても同じところに繋げるようにしているんです
そちらで連絡するんです
でも そういう人々も同じ目になったら何するかわからないでしょうと思いますけど
で その緊張感なんですね
逃げよう それが良いストレスなんです
まあそれにももうなかなか単語はないんです
パーリ語では単語はちゃんとあります
この仏教を聞くと まああまり私はさせてないんですけど
もうものすごいストレスかかるようにするんです
ものすごい脅迫されちゃって
もういてもたってもいられない状態も作るんです
作って ではあなたどうしますか？と
そうするともう逃げる気持ちはなるんです
解脱する気持ちが それで解脱する
悟り開けると だから信じられないほどもう並大抵じゃないんですよ
ものすごいストレスを感じないと悟れないんです
でも そのストレスと瞑想は進めない
普段のストレスとは随分違うんです
そこも覚えておいてください
一応 2種類あります 俗世間の言葉で言えば
なんかワクワクしている気持ちといえば
俗どうせ俗世間のことだからね
何かやりたくて もうもうワクワクしていて
もういてもたってもいられない状態で
そういう状態でそのやりたいことをやると
別にストレスは溜まる
です 気分がいいんです
それが良いストレスなんです
そこで良いストレスの場合の特色は
良いストレスは先にあるんですよ
先にやって そのやりたいことをやって
ストレスも全部消えてしまってホッとするんです
悪いストレスはじわじわじわじわじわじわ溜まって自己破壊するんです
だから良いストレス 悪いストレスの判断はそういう風にするものなんです
先にストレスが溜まっても行動に行く
それが良いところなんです
はい それで次のところに行く前にもうちょっと一応理解しやすくするために答え出します
皆さん 我々日常生活で考えているストレスというのは怒りです
仏教から見れば 全部 なんとか感じで怒りが溜まるんです
怒りっていうのは心に現れると毒なすごい毒なんです
だから そのその瞬間の心が体の物質も作るんです
それで体に怒りが作った物質も毒なんです
だから心臓がイカれたり
腎臓がやられたり 内臓が機能しなくなったり
血圧が上がったり コレステロールが溜まったり
もう全部悪いことするんです
特に内臓が早く老化するんです
ストレスたまると これは仏教の考え方で
別に私は医者でも何でもないんだから
そこはまず覚えておいてください
私が言うことは決して医学には逆らいませんですけど
まあ医者は随分お金かかって苦労して言ってることですけど
我々は軽々く言うだけの話です
だからこのストレスというのは怒りです
心の中に現れる怒りが心の中にあると
体にも適切な物質がずっと化学物質が生まれます
それでどうなるかというと
もう片っ端からもう内臓からもう壊れていくんです
で 壊れることはそんな早くわかりません
人間にはかなり体力がありますから
タラランスって何でしたっけ？あの
耐耐久性 耐久性ありますから
すぐわかりません あの金属疲労という言葉はよく聞かれますね 1
日にして金属破れるわけないでしょうに
機械はゆっくりゆっくり疲労していくんです
そこで耐久できなかったところで壊れちゃいます
そこで我々の内臓の老化スピードがものすごく速くなるんです
だから よく老けて見える人っていうのは
年よりも結構ストレス溜まってるんです
で 私も同じことで日本に来ていたら
一旦国へ帰ったら親戚にもわからないほど私はすごく老けていたんです
みんなあれ？ってびっくり
で そういうことで 結構老けちゃうんですね
まあ顔表面的に老けるのはどうったことはないんですけど
この内臓を老化するということはね
そう無視することはできません
例えば歳なのに血管の年は歳とか言われると
今なんか最近そうやって部品ごとに年いっちゃうでしょうね
血管の年とか あれやこれやとかね
血液の流れは何歳ですか？とか
これはまあ面白い いろいろ機械作ったりして
データによって作っているものとか面白いと思いますよ
だから 自分が歳なのに
血管はまあ歳か歳と言われると
これはもう結構老化しているということなんです
一旦老化したら元に戻るということはもうない
難しいんじゃなくて かわいそうで
それは暗い話かもしれませんだけど
ストップすればいいんです
例えば自分が 35歳 内装はまあ 50歳だったら
内装は 50歳で止まってもらう
そうすると自分が 50歳になっちゃうとぴったしでしょうに
だからそういう方法があります
いわゆるこの老化のスピードを普通ノーマルスピードにする
老化停止はあり得ません
そうすると死ぬしかないんです
そうすると老化も何もないんだから
生きるということは老化するということですから
それは止まりません でもこれはあまりにも早くてね
意味がないんです それでこのよく理解してください
ストレスというのは怒りです
例えば楽しいことをやっていると
まあこんなことやっていられませんとかね
まああれもあれ やらなくちゃいかん
これもやらなくいかんと思った瞬間で
楽しいことに対して怒っているんです
私はこれにはもうなんかべったり付いちゃって
なかなかやめられない状態になってるんだよと
やみつきになってるんだよっていうことが怒りなんです
仕事をしていると あーこんなもん早く終わりたいと
こんな仕事 本当につまらないことをやらせているのではないかとかね
で 考えちゃうと怒りなんですよ
だから怒り ストレスというのは
仏教では単なる怒りなんです
だからあえて専門用語は使ってないんです
なぜならば 怒りと捕まってみると
もう解決方法があるんです
怒りない生き方をすればいいんです
ただ まあ答えはそれだけ
それだけ覚えておけば
今日の講義は延々とする必要はないんですけど
では ストレスの正体続き
今お説明したのは皆様がわかっているところだけ
しかし 貪瞋痴に基づく行為はストレスになります
これは悪の源泉の黙秘です
貪瞋痴で生きているでしょうに
だから 言論によると何か行為をしたら 7分の1ですけど
これは心を計算して 心は 7つ業として生まれるんです
これ  7つの中で最初の心と
いわゆる 1番目の心と 7番目の心はすごく弱いんです
寿命はないんです それで最初の心の業が今世で結果出すんです
来世まではもう持てません
賞味期限切れちゃうんです
7番目の心の業は 次生次の生まれだったら結果出すんです
3番目の生まれ変わりにはもう賞味期限切れてるんです
だから 2から6までは輪廻でいる間はいつも
でも結果出せるんです
だから一つの行為 業にしたっても
仏教の場合はそうやって３つに分けてます
そこで我々はもう毎日ちょんりんちで生きてるでしょうし
だからこの３セットの業をしているんです
それでストレスというのは結果であって
それは自分やってる 悪いことやってますよ
仕事に行くのは悪いことじゃないんだけど
貪瞋痴だから悪いことになるんです
子育てとは自然のことで
決して悪いことじゃ悪いことでもいいことでもなんでもないんです
ただ子育てするだけの話なんです
でもこれはえらい欲情でわがままでもう自我でやっちゃいますから
全部罪になっちゃうんです
そうすると必ずしも悪いことをしているんだから
もう報いがあるんです
これで現世で この世で受ける報いがストレスなんです
冗談のように聞けるんですけど
ものすごい真面目な話なんです
だからこの体がね もう突然
突然ではなくて じわじわとがんになって変わっ
がんに変わったりするは
あらゆる病気になりますよ
内臓がね もう突然なんか異常現象を起こしたりする
どうにもならなくなっちゃう
腎症 腎臓っていうのは
まあもう死んでしまったりする
人間の体っていうのは結構しぶとくしぶといんだから
腎臓１個なくなっても
もう１個はもう動くし
あるいは別なものを付け加えれば
それで機能してくれるしとか
そういうこともありますから
私はもうなんでなんでももう二つ二つあるのかっていうことは
これが面白いんですね
目は２つは耳が２つと
もう食物以外は全部ほとんど２つ ２
つというかね だから１つ故障したらもう１つでも機能できるんです
そういうことで 不貪不瞋不痴の行為によってストレスではなく
活発的になるエネルギーが溜まるのです
それは良いストレスなんです
我々はむさぼりと怒りと無知でもう行動すると悪いストレスばっかり溜まる
不貪不瞋不痴という いわゆるむさぼらないこと
怒らないこと 智慧を使うこと
そういうことで生活すると当然たまるものはたまりますよ
しかし 良いことをしているんだから良いものたまるんです
だからもう体が明るくなるは
もう体も顔色も綺麗になる
病気なんかにはほとんどかからなくなっちゃう
年取ることはゆっくりのんびりと年を取る
しかし 行動することは結構早く行動する
なんだかんだもすぐすぐ早く早くやって終わっちゃうんだけど
本人の年取ることだけはすごい遅い
で 普通の場合は逆ですから
やることは何でも遅くて失敗ばっかり
でも10回ぐらい繰り返して時間なくなりますけど
年取ることはみるみるうちに年取ってるんです
それは悪いストレスの場合なんです
良いストレスの場合は
それ逆転するんです 年はすごくのんびり年取る
しかし 毎日のことはもうテキパキとすごい早くやる
すごい活発的になります
あの経典なんかに出てくる
このあのある時期で 人間には寿命はすごく長かったと
若い 若い時もまあ４と 4万8000円でしたと
中年で 4万8000年で
それから年取ってからまた 4万8000年でもう３つですよ 4
万8000年はもう計算できんだけど
まあこれ 4万8000というのは
もしかするとこのパーリ語で言うと結構響きのいい数字なんです
だからと思いますけど
かなり長いという意味ではないかなと思います
しかし 300年 寿命は 4万8000年にはしません
数学はそれなりにインド人も知ってましたからね
無数という数字まで計算できたんだから
いわゆる10の何倍でしたっけ
もうかなり数字ですよ
信じられないほどの数
そこまで計算チャートできてましたし
だから計算できなかったってわけじゃないんだけど
数字で言うと大体アバウトでいいところで区切って言うんです
科学も同じでしょ 今からもう 3万何年前で何々が現れたか
あれ すごいアバウト いい加減でしょ
そういう感じで この年がすごい長い時はなんで年が長かったというと
怒りと欲がないんだと
その人々は 憎しんだり
悔しがったり そういうことはなかったと
不自由もしたり それ何もない
すごい自然の流れで生きていたんだと
欲はない 子供を作ることには
やっぱり子供を作らなくてはという感じで
では子供を作りましょうと
それで終わりと あの人は美人だ
あの人は美男だとか追っかけで行ったりとかね
それはまるっきりない
だから今とはまるっきり違う生活でしたと
それでものすごく寿命は長かったと
だから今の我々は この嫌な欲と怒りをね
なくして 落ち着いて にこにこ
明るいでにこにこと笑って生活すると
何でも早くできるようになる
後回しにしない仕事なんかは楽しくてたまらないんだから
それは仕事は早くなるんですけど
本人の老けるスピードはもうギリギリ遅く
のんびりと年取るんです
そういうケース見たことはいくらでもあるでしょう
結構明るく元気でものすごい元気で頑張っている人々はなかなか若いでしょう
なかなか若いんです だから別に私は嘘言ってるわけじゃないんです
いつでもそれは事実なんです
それで俗世間は 普通の世界は貪瞋痴の行動しか知らないんですよ
例えば欲は良くないと言ったって
あれ 欲がないとどうやって生きていられますか？と平気で聞くでしょう
それから人を助けることやらボランティアやら
あればまるっきり特別な行為であって
ある特定の人がやることであるというふうに思っているんです
だから 普通婦人愚痴っていうのはもう知ったものではありません
人に何かしてあげなさい
助けなさいということをさせるためには
ものすごい苦労しなくちゃいけないんです
自分のお金で何か誰かにあげるということは
ものの何かすごいおかしいことのように
本当にあげなくちゃいけないんでしょうか？とかね
もう考えて考えて 自分が全く変なことをやるというぐらい
すごい苦労するんですよ
だから 脳の中にそういうプログラムがないんです
だから この養老先生の言葉で言えば
そんなのは存在しないんです
布団夫人プチっていうのは
我々には そこら辺が あの養老先生の本を読んでみてください
随分淡々と簡単に書いています
だから 実 何でしたっけ？実態じゃなくて
事実 現実って何なのかと
だから先生の例で言えば
なんか道路を歩いているとゾウムシでしたっけ？なんとか虫見たら
先生はすぐ足を止まって
それを観察する くるんだと
でも他の人はほとんど見えませんと
見ても なんとか生き物という感じで通っていくんだと
でもそちら辺で円玉でも落ちていたら
すぐ足が止まるんだと
そこで人間にとっては円っていうのは存在する事実であって
実在するものであって
ゾウムシは存在しないんだと
自分が小さい時からそういう虫を集めたり
研究したりしていたんだから
随分興味があるんだと
ということで威張っているんです
私は あんたは未だに虫殺してるんでしょうかと聞きたいところもありますけどね
いい加減やめなさいと
標本作ったりも くだらんことであるにも
どう見たっても放っておけばいいですよ
虫たちを だから立派に人生論を書いたあの先生に
虫たちから見ればえらい迷惑な
俗世間では知らない では
次にまたストレスの正体ですけど
世の中では生産能力というんですか
これ言葉正しいかどうか分かりませんが
もう勝手に書いた言葉だから
一応まあプロダクションというものはね
生産能力が上がるなら
怒り 欲も怒りも良いものと見なしてます
随分何も知らない 心の働きなんかは
欲も悪く悪くないんですよ
みんな一生懸命頑張ってくれるんだったら
だからこの間テレビで見たんですけど
どこかの会社でこのやる気を出すために
一番この能力が悪い社員たちにボーナスを袋に入れる作業をさせるんです
それで一人には万とか
もう一人にはもう万とか
もう一人には万とか 自分の名前ある人にも万円とかに
すごく悔しい思いでわざとさせる
それで社長自身でボーナスを渡すんです
手渡し その時もテレビで見たんですけど
来る人の名前じゃなくて
一番ボーナスのまあ一応順番に来るんだから
上の人からで一番上の人でもボーナスは高いというわけでもないし
ボーナス一番高い すごい厚い袋ある
それ持っているんですね
持っててありがとうございます
それ渡す 渡そうとして
本人もそれ取って手で感触感じるんですね
それで あ 違いますと言って本人の袋あげるんです
だからみんな一番高いボーナスもらっている人はどれぐらいもらっているかっていうことは
自分で手で触っているんです
この万円札の束の厚さを
それ何のためにやらせるかというと
もう社員たちをやる気を出すためで
能率をさらに向上させるためでしょ
何を使っているんですか？怒りでよくないんです
それが世間ではいい社長やと言って言うでしょう
人に罪を犯して だからもう頑張るのは頑張るんだけど
その社員たちも怒りか欲で頑張るんです
悔しさで 悔しいということは欲なんです
時々そんなお金なくてもいいやというふうに思っているかもしれませんよ
まあ私にはまあ円 万ぐらいあれば十分やという人々もいますよ
別にそんな欲がない しかし
欲がなくても悔しさがあるでしょうに
だから万円のボーナスはいらんだけど
悔しいんです 自分の部下が万で
自分がなんで万ですかと
だから そういうふうに人を仕事をやる気にさせても危険ですよ
それでうまくいかなくなっちゃう人もいくらでもいますからね
ストレスたまるんです
そこで次に書いてることも
まあただ読めばわかることで
生産能率に悪影響がある時のみ貪瞋痴に悪口を
例えば欲で楽しくていて
仕事には気がいかない
怒りで悔しくて仕事をしない時だけ悪口を言うんです
あんた これ怒りは良くないんだぞとか
あなたの欲は良くないんだぞとかね
それが世界のやり方なんです
貪瞋痴が能率をアップしてくれるならば
いいもので で 仕事の能率が減るんだったら貪瞋痴が悪いんであって
結局はだから考えてみると
世の中は何を考えているんでしょうかと
ただ儲かるかないか ただそれだけ
何のために儲かるか それはどうでもいいんです
人間がいるんだから 儲かる儲からないが成り立つでしょうし
だから人間の命は大事だということをまるっきり考えていない
何よりも大事なのは あなたは生きていることではないかと
だから養老先生の本なんかはものすごく
なんでベストセラーというと
人間全く知ったことがないことは言ってるんだからなんです
そこで俗世間から見れば
俗世間はありがたがる
羨ましがる存在で もう何でもまあいわゆる儲かる世界の頂点にいるんだから
もう狩れる能力は全部ついているんだから
それでその人は何か言うと耳を傾ける
他の人言うと聞いてくれない
存在もしない 実体はない
で でもその先生も言っているのは
やっぱりもうちょっと違うものがあるんじゃないかなというね
儲かることは命ではなくて
命があるんだから儲かることは成り立つんであるんだよ
はっきりする だから逆さ眼鏡ということは
そういうことところでも育っていると思います
あの先生 用語を使ってはいるんですけど
かなり真剣に用語に分析して合わせてってところはないんです
ですから 何でしたっけ？同じストレスがある時は味方です
ある時は敵なのです 俗世間では
だって怒り欲がもうあって
仕事に頑張ってくれると
怒りで欲っていうのは味方です
怒りで欲で仕事はうまくいかない
会社に行かなくなっちゃうと敵なんです
そこで私にもいろいろアドバイス聞く場合あるんですけど
アドバイスできないんですよ
会社に行けなくなっちゃったと調べてみると
あまりにも欲 怒りでもう機能しなくなってるんです
体は そこで私は怒りを作ってあげなくちゃいけないんですね
別な 会社に行くぞという
これがもう良くないし
意味がないし やりたくはないんです
だったら 俗世間にいる高い金を取るカウンセラーの方に行った方がいいんです
こちらに来るならば 完治する方法
本当の対処方法を聞きたければ
まあ私のところに来ても構いません
本当に完治したいと思うならば
これは俗世間の見方ですね
では それで正体はそんなもんです
ストレスの正体は 結論としては怒りだとわかった方がいいんです
というと 楽しいことをやる時でも
結局どこかで怒りが溜まるんです
怒りも嫌だ嫌だという気持ちは
そうでなくても楽しいこと
それでストレス溜まるんですよ
なぜならば あれは業の結果なんです
欲が現れると 次に結構ストレス溜まるんです
すごい疲れます でも覚えておいてください
はい で 対処法 まず世間の対処法
世間のやり方は毒を盛って毒を毒を以て制する方法ですね
まあもう説明したんだからね
わかると思います これはもっと悪く言えば抗がん剤治療と似ています
がんになったら治療するでしょう
治療自体は絶対人間の体には触れてはいけないものばっかりなんです
がん治療する技術屋さんも
全部自分をきちんと体を守って
安全なところにいて 機械で操作して治療するんです
放射治療なんかする時でも同じことで
ちゃんと当てて逃げるんです
逃げて遠隔装置でやるんです
あるいは今はそうでもなくて
全部自動的にセッティングしているんだから
放射量と時間と面積っていうのは全部自動的にコンピューターでコントロールしてやりますから
もう技術屋さんが結構そばにいなくても大丈夫
古い機械にしたっても
タイマーを合わせて全部レディエーションレベルとかなんとかとか合わせて
きちんと紙を見て合わせてじーっと見ているんです
終わったらカチカチとスイッチオフしてすぐ行かない
患者のところに 体中放射能漏れはしていますからね
そこで自分が別な服を着て
もうほとんど触ろうともしないで運んでもう放り込むんです
あんな危険なものは もうがんで
体がクタクタ もう疲れて壊れてる人にも当てると
もう信じられないほど苦しいんですよ
でもそれしか方法は見つからないというか
もう出てこないんです
だから小さい時からの貪瞋痴を置いておけば
がんにならないのに 完治は決して考えていないのです
ストレスさえもわかってないんだから
もういいものやと思ってるしね
ある程度で脳リスクだけ上がるんだったらいいものやと
だから完治っていうのは俗世間ではない
その時なんとかすればいいということで
時々欲あること ストレスで悩むことを自慢にするんですよ
そんなもんですよ 俗世間は
はい それから仏教の 対処方法
まずストレスを直視するんですね
心を直視してもらうんです
これ知らない人々は腹が立って帰りますけど
これが完治する方法なんです
私も突然 あんたものすごい怒ってるんではないかと
相当あんた馬鹿者でしょうと平気で言うんですよ
立派な知識人に向かって
それでもアメリカ人に言われたら
その通りやと思いますけど
私に言われるんだから
結構腹が立って もう二度と顔のところか
もう仏教と聞いたところからも逃げると思いますね
でもそれが治す方法なんです
ごまかしつつも どこかに大学に入って勉強したかもしれませんだけど
バカはバカだから 人生失敗してるんだったらバカに決まってるでしょうに
なんで客観的に具体的に見ないんですか？私は東大出たんだから頭がいいんだよと
誰がそんなこと信じるんですか？日本人そう思うかもしれませんだけど
外人にとっては東大でも明大でもどちらでも同じですけど
外人から見れば もっともっと校舎が立派に綺麗にできて
できて 環境も良くていいところだったら
いい大学だなと思いますけど
食堂も綺麗で 食べ物もいい食べ物があるんだったら
だから 私は東大が出ているんだからかなりの知識人だと思っても
やっぱり具体的に見ると人生は失敗でしょうと
ある人が来て もうもうダメですと病院に連れて行ったんですけど
とにかく話を聞かない
言うわ言うわ 自分が精神的にイカれて病気ということも本人は知ってるんだけど
それはまず認めたくない
周りには頭が悪いんだと
そんなタイプ 明らかに普通の精神病患者と同じなんですよ
世界が狂ってるんだと言うんだからね
で 言っちゃうともういきなり自分がもうものすごく頭が良くて
感覚が鋭くて いろんなことはもう無茶勉強しているんだと
そんなに言いたければ
じゃあ学歴やらなんだかんだ言ってくださいと聞いてもらったんです
それから私はいろんなことを言って
いくらなんでも でもあんた頭が悪いでしょ
何もデータの整理できんでしょうにと
だから全く知らない人と何が違いますかと
いろいろ言いましたけど
全くできなかったんです
直すのは 何回何回も来ましたけど
まあすごい凶暴になったり
それだったらどこかでまあ放り込んで閉じ込むしか方法ないんです
ですから直視するということは必要なんです
俗世間でいう学歴やら卒業証明書やらね
そんなものは何の意味もないんですよ
自分が毎日どう生きているかっていうことが問題なんです
だからそこら辺でちゃんと心の状況を直視する
それでストレス見るんではなくて
それを作った感情を発見する
ストレスというのは見えるものでもないし
ただ気分が悪いだけのことだから
気分が悪い 気分が悪いと見ても意味がないんです
どんな感情でいると その気分が悪くなるのかと
例えば仕事をするとき
ストレスが溜まるんだったら
どんな感情で仕事をするときはストレス溜まるのかと
それを発見するんです
仕事をすると必ずストレスが溜まるんだぞという
この大雑把ないい加減なこのもう言い方良くないんですよ
これは英語で言えばスイーピングステートの全部まとめて掃除して言うというやり方は良くないんです
ちゃんとゴミを分別しないと
ゴミだからって全部まとめていっぺんにポイと捨てるか
できんだから だから仕事に行ったらストレス溜まるって言ったっても
毎日溜まるのかと 月曜日から金曜日か土曜日まで
朝入社した時から 会社に入った時から出る時まですーっと溜まってるんでしょうかと
ちゃんと分 何て言いますか
このゴミの分解しないと
分解なんて言いますか
この分けをゴミ分けしないと
ちゃんと そうすると このどんな時ストレス溜まるかと自分の気持ち
感情が発見できるんですよ
で それ難しいというならば
私は答えを出します それは貪瞋痴のいずれかです
そんな感情なんか発見しなくて言ったっても難しいんだよと言うでしょうに
では答えます 貪瞋痴です
いずれかです それでその感情を発見すればいいんです
次に その過程を見る それで例も書いてあります
欲とその原因でストレスが溜まっていくことを観察する
例えば欲だと思っちゃうと
仕事をしていると欲が出てくる
なんだかんだ欲といえばすごいたくさんありますよ
例えば もう何でしょうかね
見事にぴったし立派な仕事をやるぞと思うと
それも欲でしょうし みんな驚かせてやるぞと
あれってあなたにそんなに才能があったのかとびっくりさせてやるそうと
それは自分の自慢で欲なんですよ
そんなことで仕事は実際できるのかと
だからそうやって無理に踏ん張っちゃうと
無理という無理に踏ん張るではなくて
無理ということに踏ん張るとストレス溜まるんですね
そこで欲が発見するはずなんです
では この欲で仕事をするとストレスが溜まりました
そうやって発見するんです
次に 答えは同じ仕事も欲がなくてもできると
みんな驚かせてやるぞとか
なんとか思わなくても仕事はできますよ
そうやってストレスが感情がなくてもできるということを発見する
で 時間はすごい早く 進みますけど
話は進めないんですね
じゃあ対処法 次 貪瞋痴の代わりに
より明るい より行動的な
より能率が高い 布団不尽不痴の気持ちもあることを発見する
これが自分で頑張って発見しないと
今は知らない 布団不尽不痴って何なのかと
ヴィパッサナー瞑想する人々さえもほとんど発見できてないんです
大変なことです そうすると無理
まあまあ無理でもないんですけど
俗世間ではもうそんなに難しくなく発見できます
瞑想の場合は 私は別にそれを発見させてやるぞという気持ちもないし
もうとにかく早く修行を終了すればいいんだから
ヴィパッサナーの見方はすごい違いますからね
そんなところはあまり気にしません
でも俗世間できる場合は
やっぱり布団不尽不痴を発見した方がいいんです
それで説明していきます
発見の手助け むさぼりの代わりに
いわゆる布団って何なのかと
えーっとなんですか 貢献的
献身的 公器的という言葉はいかがでしょうかと
仕事をやってみんなを驚かすんではなくて
まあこれはやってあげますと
自分が小さくて 何か社会に対して奉仕する
別にその言葉は正しい
ぴったし正しいわけじゃなくて
これはなんとなくこのヒントですよ
布団を理解するための
俺が儲かるぞという気持ちはもう明らかに欲ですよ
ではなくて 献身的にこういうことを作ってあげようではないか
この自分が今開発する機械は
みんな使うとみんなすごく便利になるんだぞと
そういう世界のことを他人様のことを考えて
献身的でやる もっと奉納という言葉を使った方がいいんですけど
いろいろガチャガチャ言われるだから使わなかったんです
奉納献上 そういう言葉でもこの感じがつかまれると思います
だからそれも付け加えてください
奉納献上 で 見返りより他人が助かることと
他人の役に立つことを重視する
何をやっても見返りではなくて
これで助かるでしょうと
それでよかったと それでストップするんです
相手に仕事して役に立ちます
役に立ちました なんとか
ああ よかったと では 私にお金くれっていうことまで言ってはいけないんです
仕事の場合はどうせ契約してますけどね
この仕事はこれぐらいお金やと
でも仕事する人はこれぐらいお金の仕事だから
できるだけ手抜きやりたい放題やったりしてね
材料は安いものを入れたりとかね
契約ってないものでも
早く仕事を終わりましょうと
そうするともう 100万円の契約なんですけど
で 普段やると これには全部 40 万かかりますと
しかしこれ何とかして 20 万で抑えて儲かりそうというふうな感じで
もうかることしか考えてないんですよ
だから仕事はきつくなるわ
相手は敵になるわ そこで仕事の内容を調べてOK出してお金 OK
しようかなと思っちゃうと
手抜きしちゃうともうやり直しになっちゃうでしょ
そうすると 100 ではなくて
もっと損しちゃうし やり直しには
そうすると仕事を頼んだ側が必ずしも敵になるんですよ
調べる側は裁判にかける
弁護士やらみんなもう悪魔敵
この会社に対してものすごい余計なんですね
どちらでも困るでしょう
だから仕事をして 献身的で
それでどうですか？仕事は
うちの仕事は それで頼んだ人は立派にやりました
これでも思ったよりもすごいと言えるならば
それでよかった よかったと
そうすると敵がいないでしょうに
そうすると では早くお金くれと言わなくても
仕事を頼んだ側がもう早くもお金をあげるんです
それで仏教のやり方なんです
はい 次に 怒りの代わりにどうしましょうかと
怒りの代わりに不尽と言うんですけど
わからないんですね 婦人って何なのかと
だったら慈しみ 他人に優しくなる
いたわる気持ち そんなもので考えてみてください
そうするとこれわかるんです
すべての生命と自然とともに生きる仲間意識
もう自分の仕事ではなくなる
それは世界ワンシステムでつなげていることで
みんな互いに協力し合って生きているのではないかと
自然とも協力し合って生きているのではないかと
それがすごい大事に重視して考えるんです
そうすると不尽という気持ちがわかるはずなんです
結構エネルギーですよ
怒って仕事をやるよりも
ものすごいエネルギーなんです
貪瞋痴の反対で 不貪不瞋不痴っていうのはただのゼロではないんです
言葉で見ればそうなりますけど
それはお釈迦様がある目的があって
不貪不瞋不痴にしているんです
それに文句を言うことはできません
しかし こういう風に考えてみてください
不尽っていうのは怒らないということが
ただ怒らないだけではなくて
かなり強烈な ポジティブな
明るい 活発的なエネルギーなんです
勝ち取りたいという怒りより
互いの協力 共存を重視する
やってみてください ストレスなんか 1掛かりもなくなります
それで不尽の理解できると思います
難しいのは次なんです
無知というか 知の代わりに
探求心 発見する心 物事を理解する気持ち
何か新しいことにチャレンジしたい気持ち
ダラダラして生きてるんじゃなくて
ちょっと調べる もうちょっと考える
もうちょっと試す なんとかちょっとチャレンジするという風な
このすごいアクティブな気分なんです
言われるからやる気持ちより
やりたいから面白いから
勉強になるからやるという気持ちを重視する
会社でも命令されたらやるだけでしょう
みんな言われるからやる人生だから
マニュアルを持ってそれもページをめくってもう仕事をする
面白くない人生だなと思いますけど
かなりみんなしぶといなと思います
私だったらもうやりません
あれほど面白くない人生でずっと年とか生きてるんだから
だから面白いから 勉強になるんだから
やりたいんだから やってみたいんだからという感じで何でもするんです
それはプチという知恵が働くエネルギーなんです
それで良いストレスですよ
溜まったっても 溜まってよかったということ
仕事終わったらもうよかった
いろいろ勉強になったと
よかった よかったということで終わっちゃうんです
だからその溜まったものはいいストレスなんです
それで対処法を終わります
テーマもそこら辺で終わりますけど
ということで ちょっと休憩します